بيان من البيت الأبيض بأن
زعيم داعش
قد مات أو كما يقولون من
ساحة المعركة باربرا ستار بأحدث ما
يمكن أن تخبرنا به
هذا الشخص الذي يدعى القرشي هو
خليفة قيادة داعش  بالطبع
بعد مقتل البغدادي قبل بضع
سنوات خلال إدارة ترامب ،
نتوقع أن نسمع المزيد من البيت الأبيض
ما يقوله البنتاغون حتى الآن هو
أن هذه كانت مهمة عمليات خاصة ناجحة
الآن وهذا يخبرنا
أن العمليات الخاصة بدأت
الأرض بطائرة هليكوبتر وكان من الممكن أن
يكون هذا من أكثر
قوات العمليات الخاصة النخبة المدربة تدريباً عالياً ،
نفهم أن
هذا هو الشيء الذي يسمى jsoc ،
قيادة العمليات الخاصة المشتركة التي
تشرف على وحدات مثل فريق الختم السادس
، قوة دلتا التابعة للجيش ، هؤلاء هم الأفضل من
أفضل ما لديهم من خبرة في ما يفعلونه
الآن ، نحن قادرون الآن على تأكيد أن إحدى
طائرات الهليكوبتر الخاصة بهم عانت من
مشكلة ميكانيكية لم تكن كذلك  قادرة على
تحليق تلك المروحية وتم تفجيرها من
قبل القوات الأمريكية بالطبع
لذلك لن تقع في أيدي العدو يقول
أفراد الدفاع المدني السوري على الأرض إن 13
شخصًا من بينهم ستة أطفال
قتلوا وسيتم التحقيق معنا وسيتم إخبارنا كيف
ذلك  حدث كل شيء
أه الآن لا أحد يقول
إن القوات الأمريكية كانت مسؤولة
عن وقوع عدد من الانفجارات
بالموقع كان هناك الكثير من إطلاق النار
بعض الخيارات الأخرى التي
رأيناها في السابق يمكن أن تكون
المتفجرات في الموقع قد انفجرت
لا نعرف حتى الآن أن هذا
سيكون سؤالًا رئيسيًا يجب طرحه ، لكن
يبدو أن الرئيس بايدن مثل العديد من
أسلافه الآن لديه ما
يعتبره فوزًا
في عمود مكافحة الإرهاب